don't have a plan B go all in there's no
other alternative please welcome Joel
kenman like most people in America my
introduction to you was in The Killing
yo Biff how's it hanging and then now
here you are like the hardest working
man in Hollywood like you're all over
the place finding acting gave me this
whole purpose in life and then I would
start getting panic attacks I would
throw up every time before I went on
stage it's like these demons
that are in my head like these voices
that like me that ruin
everything like what is the worst thing
that they could
experience that's where everything
changed if you have that facility to not
shy away from those things then you're
in this sort of curious growth mindset
way of approaching your life good
conversation did I find my
therapist